[Musik]
sieg in folge
region
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
hallo herzlich willkommen sozialismus
ich bin gerade in köln auf der
süßwarenmesse die internationale
süßwarenmesse ist wirklich die größte
süßwasser weltweit hier gibt's
aussteller aus deutschland hier gibt's
aussteller von der ganzen welt süßwaren
snacks gesundes ungesundes weniger fett
es gibt ja alles um die süßwarenmesse
ist für alle fachbesucher das heißt sie
kann jeder seine waren ausstellen dann
kommen die einkäufer schauen das tolle
ist was vielleicht nicht so toll ist und
dann stets für euch irgendwann später
mal im regal oder in online-shops und
ich bin jetzt zum vierten jahr auf der
süßwarenmesse das heißt ich kenne mich
hier eigentlich schon aus ich glaube die
meisten kennen uns auch schon wie so
eine kleine familie also die
lebensmittelindustrie ist gar nicht so
groß wie man denkt wir waren auch schon
auf ganz vielen anderen veranstaltungen
man sieht dass immer die gleichen leute
jetzt sind wir hier um nach den trends
2018 zu schauen
wir gucken mal hier was es alles gibt
ich bin hier immer am gleichen standort
bei deko parks zu haben wir angefangen
so machen wir weiter
hier zeigt sich die ganzen neuheiten im
bereich kochen nein ich im bereich poren
ich zeige euch den neuheiten eben
bereich wachsen und dekorieren da geht
es nicht ganz tolle innovationen die wir
auch gemeinsam entwickelt haben und dann
schauen wir mal was es hier so alles
gibt letztes jahr war er hätte trend
ganz groß einhorn überall waren
einhörner mal schauen was dieses jahr
ist und ich denke der trend geht
vielleicht in richtung video oder für
firmen wir gucken einfach mal
[Musik]
die schweiz habe ich das gefühl als
würde ich hier an geklotzt werden was
glaubt ihr so gibt einfach stände hier
dann muss es einfach jedes jahr hin weil
sie einfach kunst drin weil sie cool
sind und weil ich einfach nicht dran
vorbei kommen also wir schauen jetzt mal
bei toll ihr ein
hans-joachim ihr habt einfach ein cooles
uns heute eben sehr kreativ sind viele
kreative kräfte bei euch wir haben hier
im prinzip alle sketche lembecker wir
haben es innovativ lustig gruselig wie
viel von bottrop
hier gibt es alles was sauber jetzt
packen wir eine richtig schöne tüte der
zuschauer und ihr könnt dann einfach
kommentieren mit tolle preise gewinnen
möchte
[Musik]
st
ich bin also entlang gelaufen und dieser
stand ist sofort ins auge gefallen und
zwar kapiert dass stand besteht komplett
aus europaletten und die paletten die
hier verwendet wurden werden später
wieder abgebaut wieder eingeführt das
heißt der nachhaltig gedacht hat jetzt
kennt ihr euch alle die haben die veggie
produkte schon seit jahren dennoch
betonte albert trend überhaupt
angefangen hat die schau mir zwar rein
und ich weiß wir haben einen neuen
werbespot der so ein bisschen für
gespräch gesorgt hat also positive
gespräche
wer ein bisschen vielleicht auch an
expression sorgt ich darf man spricht
auf jeden fall gebaut und wir schauen
jetzt mal was neues haben
herzstück 18 mal draußen jetzt achtet
darauf dass ihr vor mir liegt ist
nämlich dass innovationen und 24 35
zimmer ausgewählt wir haben die partie
jetzt sommer lebe mit joghurt und
vitamine
katjes wunderland in der pink edition
ist die vierte edition das heißt hier
geht da ein und trends einfach noch ein
bisschen weiter und wir haben noch den
katjes sternen tänzer und die produkte
sind zum einen trug superlecker sehen
und da der sommer ja anrufen weit weg
ist aber wir alle bis zum sommer auf dem
tisch haben wollen können das ja mal mit
das sommer edition ausprobieren mit der
casting normale habe ich den jungs
geschmack denn geschmack und natürlich
alles möglich danke
alles nur für euch
[Musik]
die warnung gab es ich liebe viel
braucht ihr habt einfach am besten du
machst die praline
wilsbergs ich habe hier schon zusehen
musste dass ich hier bin auf der messe
ich bin ich jemand vorbeikommen ein
leckeres essen was heute uns mit dem
auto gut
ja es macht gleich auch das pläne für
euch aber eine frage habe ich vorher was
macht man eigentlich ein gutes nougat
aus da habe ich mein vorschlag vom
einfach mal in unseren oberfeld nach
schnell und dann zeige ich dir weh guten
entsteht ja ja ja ist sie eingeladen
okay das machen werde ich glaube ihr
fällt dieses jahr auf jubiläum 125 jahre
gibt es uns schon nach 25 jahren u 20
das machen wir gehen zusammen und machen
dann lukas selber und jetzt mache ich
eine parallele
[Musik]
und vielleicht magst du das nach dem
überreichen
ich habe nämlich kein geschenk für ihren
mann des jahres
der winter war perfekt danke auf den
essig marzipan mit farb peter mein
favorit danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
326 stimmen
vom mann des jahres zum hanna des jahres
lieberman könnte ich mich stundenlang
unterhalten ich könnte stundenlang hier
stehen und natürlich auch alles
probieren die waffe kennt und die mama
war schon immer vegan schon bevor man
wusste was legal ist ist lecker ist es
schon immer ist es auch heute noch und
schaue mir mal ein bisschen was haben
und was gibts ja gesagt wir kennen uns
ja schon länger seit zwei jahren auch
schon zusammengepackt
so ist eine schwarzwälder kirschtorte
lecker und spaß gemacht ja ich glaube
schon gruppe dauer und es war eine
schöne sache
wir wollen dem trend folgen weniger süß
weniger zum produkt und deswegen haben
wir die serie tragen schwarze richtungen
sind übrigens auch die drei stärksten
geschmacksrichtungen diese waffe bereich
schokolade
ich liebe alle drei aber der pass ist
einfach mein favorit ist der förderkreis
grundsätzlich die stärkste
geschmacksrichtungen wie es gibt
überhaupt eine waffe bereich und die
sind aber alle drei sehr gut geworden
und wir wollen diesen ländern folge
leisten
ich glaube wenn man den namen man also
in die runde wirft jeder waffe absolut
jeder dieser schritte in der waffel in
deutschland in rosa gesicht gegeben und
das machen wir seit vielen jahren seit
jahren sie immer als in deutschland
aktiv ich dachte ja immer dass nur die
erwartungen
dieses produkt ich kannte immer nur dass
hier das kind mal jahren
und dann war ich bei intersport
österreich da sind wir auch mit dabei
über uns da also regale voll dass er die
regale voll wird euren produkten warum
gibt es nicht bei uns es gibt ja schon
ein paar mehr als diese bruderliebe
haben also verschiedene
geschmacksrichtungen überwiegend über
waffeln und ich mag in deutschland ist
dann schon etwas anders als in
deutschland wirklich ich habe immer
gedacht der österreicher die deutschen
so ähnlich ist was dran
es gibt produkte die sehr speziell sind
schokolade beispiel produziert und
schokolade von der kakaobohne weg aber
in deutschland profitieren da eben man
mit waffeln
das sind um uns doch schon mal ein
bisschen schwerer dann gibt es dann
nicht mal sehr aufpassen jungle gebaut
ist konnte deutschen auch ein bisschen
schwer weil man ja diese italienische
war
viele möglichkeiten und glauben dass wir
weiter wachsen
vielleicht sollte ich einfach ein
bisschen mehr mit dem gestreckten
bakterium dass wir eine gute sache es
gibt auch verschiedene rezepte die wir
schon haben und erst bestimmt auch so
prozent der täter unter tel
und dann habe ich mit ihm also sie
schmecken mir auch sehr gutes und vielen
guten anklang aber es ist manchmal etwas
schwierig dann alle verbraucher zu
erreichen dass der handel dann sagt die
produkte so gut im opfer kauf dass sie
dann auch den läden zu finden sind und
weggeführt worden ich liebe männer so
ein richtig traditionsunternehmen für
mich und ich nehme diese schnitte mit
und hier noch gleich ist es das auto
scan alle seit 1898 waren können und
ziehen wird auch unverändert von einem
zu tun
dieses thema vegan gibt es schon seit
seit 98 ohne das war eine rezeptur aus
kanada
super dann kannst du gleich noch was mir
meine zuschauer doch vielen vielen tagen
dabei muss man schon ganz gut
danke
[Musik]
wie viel gelaufen dass frauen eine
kaffeepause
seinen kaffee haben
[Musik]
dankeschön spieltagen perfekt kaffee ist
doch übrigens der beste kaffee hier auf
der messe welche keks dazu die pause
habe ich mir echt verdient
dankeschön und falls ihr die tüte
gewinnen wollt ihr wisst was ihr
schreiben wirft das war uns auch dabei
er ist noch immer noch 1000
die einfach immer noch pause
wer braucht schon brot ist dass das am
liebsten
[Musik]
das wird ein glas zu leeren
jetzt bin ich mir meinen lieben schweiz
haben ich weiß ja das ist ganz viele
zuschauer dort habe und ich habe vor
einem jahr etwa einem jahr
da habe ich denn daniel kennen gelernt
aus der schweiz und zwar von der firma
ragusa und ragusa ist echtes muss man
sagen gehört schon zur premium
schokolade also premium produkte
wirklich super lecker und ich fand die
geschichte damals so interessant woher
stammt der name rakusa das ist der name
der früheren stadt dubrovnik und dann
martin küste heute kreuzen
das hatte bereits vor dem krieg und
gefunden das ist so ein schöner name das
und vielleicht hat er dort auch weil ich
weiß nicht ob es sinnvoll war das ein
guter name und das ist gleich in der
schweiz können das jesuskind rakusa du
bist noch nie in der schweiz umso mehr
vorbei mach es am abend dann machen wir
gemeinsam schokolade machen also danke
danke schön
[Musik]
hier war auch schon ganz fleißig weit
worten habe ich hin gekriegt aber ich
bin halt ein gespräch verwickelte
manuela ich ganz fleißig neben mir und
macht nur echt super viel spaß zu zweit
hier an der chance
der blaue rose torte finde ich voll
schön passt perfekt zusammen
türkis mit diesem schönen pink echt
schön
und da hat sie zum beispiel seine
valentinstag torte gemacht und eine
natürlich passend zum karneval
der clown macht genauso spagat wie
sanierer hat des amerika sommermarkt
markus und dann sitzt du schon so wie
der clown mit 50 leiter kurz verlassen
wir gehen noch mal antue
das spät
also ich habe jetzt meine lieblinge in
diesem jahr und zwar sind diese kleinen
karotten und erdbeeren
das sind einfach torten aufleger oder
ihr kennt ja auch alle rückblick kuchen
und der rückblick kuchen wird oft
dekoriert mit hässlichen kleinen mädchen
die auf gar keinem schmecken fad
ausweise zähne zu klumpen ca
und die hier sind aus weißer schokolade
schmeckt sehr lecker sind richtig dünn
und vor allem hin dass die central
hübsch und der große vorteil ist die
schmerzen einfach nicht wenn man sie
auch seine legt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alle falten geglättet
jetzt sind wir in der notabteilung beide
cucino ganz neu im sortiment und zwar
sind es torten helfer also dekoartikel
haben die man einfach einsetzen kann
werkzeuge und die sind von der qualität
her echt super die gibt es auch bei uns
natürlich online und ich verwende die
auch und das tolle bei den ist es nicht
in einfacher form und klettere sondern
ein 2 1 1 produkt einmal den großen und
dann kann ich das hier auch ab machen
und habe so einen süßen kleinen fondant
blätter also echt toll vor allem um an
ecken zu kommen oder die ränder zu
machen und genau so sind auch alle
anderen artikel also hier zum beispiel
das modell ihr werkzeug in weiß-blau
finde ich auch eine ganz tolle farbe und
der griff ist einfach super ganz reiches
silikon und medizinischem silikon es ist
sehr hochwertig und dann bekommt man
einfach keine blasen an den fingern wenn
man auch mal länger was models ich habe
mir jetzt zum beispiel auch eine neuheit
und zwar die verpasste in lila wirklich
eine ganz ganz tolle farbe mit der ja
auch cremes zum beispiel einfärben könnt
oder auch zeigt also wie die anderen
passen farben auf und das ist auch ganz
toll finde es gibt leute sind von der in
lila und pink und in hellblau und was
denn von dort besonders macht also den
von dorf und decken china
das zeigt jetzt mal kurz in der küche zu
wasser nimmt von dort natürlich genial
ist man kann den super toll weiß kneten
und trotzdem ist total stratege und ich
keine ganz dünn ausrollen und zwar
deswegen weil ich hier keinen platz mehr
drin ist sondern shea butter eigentlich
shea butter teurer als palm fest
das war wichtig dass gold kaufen oder
essen und das ist ein bisschen
ein bisschen zärtlichkeit und geschirr
mega mega falls ihr den politikern
analytikern wir kennen uns seit über
fünf jahren befreundet und er kommt auf
simplen also bei uns um die ecke
und da ist ja auch die firma decken kino
her und deswegen arbeiten wir auch immer
an gemeinsam eine produkten
produktentwicklung fotos qualität jetzt
zeigen wir mal ein bisschen was beim
ausrollen und die farben sind echt schön
und genial
also das ist schon richtig extrem dünn
zu dünn würde ich ihn wahrscheinlich bei
einer traute nie machen weil ich nicht
gewohnt war
aber so tun wirklich ein millimeter kann
ich ihn schon aus wolle und es geht
sogar noch schöner also ohne wasser reis
wirklich total elastisch und auf an den
ecken und kanten haben jetzt keine
probleme mehr gibt echt wirklich fast
schon ganz alleine schmiegt er sich
schon hat er gut gemacht kriegen sogar
männer hin
neben den neuen torten auf lägern in
rosa und blau gibt es auch den deko
schritte und auch das konfetti in
verschiedenen farben und natürlich auch
das metallic spray was ich sehr gerne
verwende natürlich alles es war und das
metallic spray verwende ich zum beispiel
gerne bei einer schablone technik und da
kann man ganz tolle glanzeffekte
erzählen was ihr natürlich auch schon in
meinen videos gesehen habt also das ist
wirklich ein absolutes lieblings produkt
von mehreren
[Musik]
denn
sie kommt
[Musik]
richtig liege
letzterer das einhorn der trend
schlechthin dieses jahr geht es um einer
und noch ein bisschen weiter
ich bin jetzt hier gerade bei küche
küche kennt ja aus meinen videos in
familienunternehmen das gibt schon seit
über 150 jahren
ich kenne ich schon seit meinem zehnten
oder elften lebensjahr durch das produkt
sommerbad kennt ihr alle benutze ich
ganz gerne um zahn oder cremes zu
festigen und jetzt bin ich hier um zu
schauen was es denn noch an neuheiten
gibt gleich aufgefallen ist mir
natürlich bibi und tina samira und
elastin nämlich die totale bibi und tina
fans rennen und singen und tanzen alle
wieder rauf und runter ich kann sie
mittlerweile auf fast auswendig und
jetzt gucken wir mal was küche für
innovationen hat und was deren produkt
2018 ist da sehe ich schon ja und zu
sein und so topthema
das haben wir natürlich was ganz neues
büro place kennt jeder gast jedoch sagen
wir mal so ich sag mal jeder dritte
kommentar unter meinen videos in letzter
zeit war immer kelly machte man den
miracles torte also eine torte mit einem
spiegel klappen und bei den mallorca ist
es halt so ist wirklich schwierig sehr
aufwendig zu machen man braucht
eigentlich ein thermometer um es genau
zu machen ganz exakt abmessen zutaten
die nicht jeder hat viele rohstoffe viel
schwierigere herstellung also es dauert
lange es traut sich nicht jeder zu das
zu machen ja nicht einfach
naja ich kann milch aufkochen 400
millilitern milch wird dieses tool
verein warten ca 20 25 minuten und
schönen sanken die temperaturen genau
und das dann mit 565 platzl geschädigtes
über die torte und haben ein tolles
ergebnis von destillaten dieses problems
auf jeden fall mal aus ich sage ich
natürlich beide varianten also einmal
grace kelly rezept und dann einfach die
einfache variante
ihr könnt ihr dann selber entscheiden
was wir machen wollt aber es hat echt
cooles innovatives produkt ganz einfach
mache ich das einfach als video was los
was möchtest du denn das ist schon
gegessen was auf den tisch hauen also
das geht nicht einfach so wie sieht bei
geld aus mit dir hast du lust auf geld
habe ich nämlich was für dich ich glaube
wir kommen ins geschäft also ihr wisst
ja ich bin nicht käuflich ich mache
nichts wofür wohin sie eigentlich stehe
ausser man kann es geld essen
es werden nochmals los
das geld ist für mich für euch habe auch
was eine tüte mit viel bibi und tina
viele küchenprodukte dankeschön
aber das geld geben
quelle dpa
[Musik]
lecker wie was sind meine lieblinge
vollkommen mit peter und kokos morath
mit
[Musik]
ein kindertraum wird war ich bin hier
bei meinem absoluten lieblingsprodukt
auf meiner kindheit bei hitler ihr kennt
alle alle die hier als kind gern
gegessen es ist aber auch heute noch
gerne aber er kennt auch ein weiteres
produkt von hitzschlag er ist vielleicht
nicht das von hitler ist aber die ufos
mit der brause die kennt auch jeder
und was ist nicht muster ich war
wirklich besser überrascht als ich mit
ticketpreisen deutsches unternehmen die
gibt es schon seit über 80 jahren ein
familienunternehmen auch hier kotschy
und ich stelle euch jetzt mal sind es
hat euch bestimmt ganz arg ich stelle
jetzt mal den fernseher vor
da ist halt so da herr hitler ich glaub
das unternehmen mit 20 jahren geht es
seit 80 jahren gibt euch also bis 100 ja
das war mein großer schon aber ja ich
habe das jetzt vor acht wochen
übernommen in vierter generation an und
macht das mit der gleichen leidenschaft
wie du und ja ich bin mir gerade eine
bürgerin und habe lange jahre in der
industrie sozusagen gearbeitet wobei der
nun habe gelernt mag in den vertrieb
aber mein herz schlägt ja doch irgendwie
war für unsere probleme jetzt mein
herzschlag
das ist halt man wenn man das macht was
man liebt dann arbeiten für ein tag in
unserem leben genauso schön so sehe ich
das auch und jan-philipp kennengelernt
vor einigen wochen in berlin
und ich muss sagen wenn man sofort in
dich verliebt also wirklich sofort also
sofort geschlossen zurück und ich weiß
was ihr da draußen jetzt denkt dass
bestimmte frage
dieser junge mann dieser junge gut
aussehende sympathische mann der so
bestimmt vergeben nein nicht alle
produkte von hitler haben möchte die
tolle geschenktüte die ja schon
vorbereitet habe oder wenn philipp man
macht einfach hersteller oder ich will
hitler
dann können wir entscheiden ob sie dicht
bekommen aber ja genauso sehen das nicht
so wie ich finde eure neuen produkte
richtig genial spinnenbeine ja unser
neues logo
richtig sauer also hilfreich wenn man
kennt es ja viele kennen den namen halt
auch nicht so richtig wie schnell ist
einvernehmen ist sie familienmarke und
jeder kennt die kunden kaum stäbchen
sie heißen das sind um rund sich sally
kennengelernt sagte sie auch der mensch
im schlaf rauben stehen die kleinen die
heißen sie noch ja die hippies und ja
werden alle leute und hergestellt sind
alle bescheid aber wirklich ist auch
ganz tolles produkt nicht ja und er
kommentiert einfach sehr gut war kenia
und verleger zur produkte und meine
lieblinge alle drei
ich bin ausgestattet danke dir
[Musik]
das paar lieblingsprodukt marzipan
das thema nachhaltigkeit fairtrade ist
natürlich immer sehr sehr wichtig vor
allem für montafon und trennt es gibt
aber auch firmen da ist nachhaltigkeit
einfach schon immer mit dabei und ich
bin so stolz dass es eine deutsche firma
ist ihr kennt ihr alle
ich bin gerade bei ritter sport ich
glaube viele wussten nicht einmal dass
ritter sport eine deutsche firma ist
seit 1912 gegründet vom alfred ritter
und eine schwäbische firma der morath
freut es natürlich ernst schwabe
tanzpartner kann darüber hinweg sehen
aber ich liebe unsere schwaben was ich
wäge ist ganz toll finde ritter sport
macht jetzt wirklich eigenen kakao aus
nachhaltiger landwirtschaft das finde
ich echt extrem super gleich eine kleine
geschichte wahrscheinlich wissen von
euch viele gar nichts mehr wie kaka
aussieht das hier sind die kakaobohnen
und sie kommen nämlich aus der kakao
frucht bewusst selber nicht wie sie
darauf ruft aussieht und eine frucht
brauchen wir für eine tafel gute ritter
sport schokolade
da gibt es ganz viele tolle sorgen und
jetzt muss man sich vorstellen dieser
cacau frucht wird mit einer machete
geöffnet das natürlich ist
verletzungsrisiko bei den bauern sei
groß und da kam ein schwäbischer tüftler
hat eine kakao sport maschine erfunden
die dahin geschickt und jetzt machen die
das ganze maschinell und so hat man
einfach kein verletzungsrisiko mehr und
kommt an die kakao holen der kakao
frucht was ich ganz toll finde ritter
sport gibt sie über 100 ländern
ich glaube die wenigsten wissen aber
dass es nur einen produktionsort gibt
uns war ich schreibe ländle
am liebsten bin ich derselbe behalten
aber auch die tasche für äußert einfach
kommunizieren mit wintersport
[Musik]
armut wächst da habe ich hier mit samira
die kuh gemolken
ich glaube dass man diese nicht ich für
das jetzt einfach
februar mit leckerem karamell
da kommt wieder leckeres uns heraus aber
ich gucke jetzt mal auf was für euch
herausspringen
schön dass du wieder da bist hast du
vielleicht hast du meine zuschauer aber
hundertprozentig ziemlich alemu fans die
man so eine richtig schöne hängen große
tiere tötet wie machen wir jetzt machen
perfekt und ihr könnt dann den hashtag
daten eingeben und dann kommt die demo
titel danke
wir sehen uns macht uns
[Musik]
yummy yummy ich gucke jetzt mal was mit
den worten hier auch nicht haben
denn wer muss verlangt kennengelernt
sympathisch nicht nur weil er den
gesetzten maßnahmen herstellerverband
ganzen haus die raucht ja ich habe alba
coach zu hause sowohl wert- und alpakas
zu hause dafür suchen wir super toll und
ihre schön spazieren ja das machen wir
ja ja ich denke die kinder mit also
nicht murat aber meine großmutter und
vielleicht über morath auch mit wer hat
in dem augenblick kam aber alpaka
spucken oft eher wird er wieder
angespuckt
an kakás weg gemacht haben ja ich denke
wir machen mit das beste machen dort
waren macht das war die rohmasse die
gute jetzt 100% 100 prozent in
deutschland ja und es ist nicht nur
markt gefahren als ich ihnen ja aber nur
mandeln und zucker sondern es gibt den
man eben in diesen worten wieder hinten
stehen also ganz toll man kann
deutlichen worten über szenen als
vorbestellung benutzen
man kann ja pralinen analysen machen man
kann es auch so lag es also super gerne
probiert formal ja das ist eine
haselnuss themen super lecker
die wird jetzt gemacht haben dann müssen
wir mal in die firma kommen das können
wir auch mal machen dann könnte ansehen
wiederhergestellt wird und so dann
machen wir mal schön super lecker so
habe ich die vögel nicht getestet
ja wir kommen auf jeden fall besuchen
glaube ich wird gegen den markt testen
zu machen sind so ich meine frau zu
fangen wir mit ja und es tipps für euch
fragen wir mal was noch voller waffen
und wir machen
ich habe auch schon los und tüten
vorbereitet dann kann ich mir dann
erzählen wie schätzt du bist gibst du
mir zwei dinge für mich in einen für
meine zuschauer durch der auch davon
habt dann müsst ihr einfach herstellen
was sie unten steht und dann bekommt ihr
diese tolle tüte und wirklich der beste
wege nicht besser gemacht aber ich habe
schon gezeichnet mit cherry tree lecker
die anderen
[Musik]
guck mal das ja auch genial hier gibt's
ein halal infopoint und hier gibt es
halt alle empfehlungs siegel da kann man
sich einfach schön informieren und das
finde ich echt genial für alle dem auch
darauf achten
[Musik]
wir werden mit offenen armen empfangen
ich kenne ihn nicht aber egal
hey
ich guck mal
kinder das ist genau meine seite glauben
manche gäste gerne reise gesagt haben
diese abgaben 6
oma
dr
na gut
andere
jetzt habe ich mir damals das
durchprobiert durch die mittel regel
ich mag ja schokoriegel nicht ganz so
gerne sind wir oft viel zu süß viel zu
mächtig also ich als frau schafft so
einen großen schokoriegel sowieso nie
wenn dann nur vielleicht mal eine mini
portionen oder ein und wissen
das finde ich ganz cool da sind wirklich
natürliche proteine mit dabei komplexe
kohlenhydrate und gesunde fettsäuren
also wirklich auch mal was was muss ich
in die handtasche stecken kann
da stecken auch kalorien mit dabei aber
ich denke einfach eine gesündere
alternative zu anderen schockiert
[Musik]
wenn wir jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz
viel hunger hat und auch keine lust auf
süßes isst weil ich muss sagen auch der
erste ich habe viel zug in süß gegessen
jetzt kommen aber auch herzhaftes in die
frage in frage
aber ich möchte auf meine figur achten
also gibt es meist maximaler geschmack
in minimaler vor bundes teste ich jetzt
mal italien pizzateig links zumindest
sehr lecker und interessant also
normalerweise kennt man ja so kleine
tranche ist eigentlich nur von süß und
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt aufs
verwirrend oder gut ist frauen nicht
nutzen
cool
man schmeckt der käse raus gewürze darf
ich noch schließt probieren decken lasse
ich aus der ist kein weg aber es geht
mir ganz okay
vegan beides okay mein erster faken
vegan ohne tierische produkte
das war lecker lecker
das muss sagen erst mal komisch weil man
es nicht gewohnt dass auf jeden fall was
neues und muss man mal ausprobiert haben
kaugummi die canton unserer kindheit und
danke macht bestimmt viel spaß
vor kurzem gesagt
alles gute schönen feierabend
[Musik]
bis dahin
kennen sie das muss ich kenne das aus
meiner kindheit die zweite stand
tatsächlich die ganze zeit über kirchen
immer von unserem stand das zeige ich
mitgenommen als skorianz das wirklich so
auf der zunge juni der sanierer
aufzeigen
weil ich war auch so als echt
[Musik]
frag mal
jetzt bin ich am ende meiner
süßwarenmesse tour die ganzen typen aber
jetzt schon ins auto das heißt die sind
für euch wenn ihr die typen gewinn wird
ihr wisst einfach den hersteller bzw den
kommentar einschreiben und dann verloren
wir die tüten euch mein resümee und mein
fazit von der messe 2018
es gibt wirklich ganz tolle innovationen
der trend zu bio fairtrade vegan begann
ist immer ein ganz ganz großes thema
aber der trend geht auch ganz schön
stark und immer stärker zu free from me
from zucker weg vom fett weg von den
kunden raten hatte machte wirklich ganz
ganz viel ich muss aber dazu sagen sie
es machen sind für mich auf genuss und
wenn man bewusst genießt und sich
ausgewogen ernährt dann darf es auch mal
eine süßigkeit sein
die rauch zu retten indem findet ist und
wir sehen uns doch mal wieder hier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da gibt es ein horn wurden ich wusste
nicht dass ein 100 hosen hat es dafür
einen herrn hahn kein geschlecht einem
stier kamel okay das ist ziemlich crazy
aber lustig mit leckerer füllung
bubblegum extras liquid ich nehme mal
dem rathaus mit
das ist aber gar kein anfang und noch
gar keinen schluss vom video keinen
anfang und kein schluss was kann man
sich sagen soll
ich helfe dir ich helfe dir anfang
schluss
keine anfänger rheinstrecke noch nicht
wir haben da schon finger drin gehabt
haben mag ich nicht so viel aber ich
denke morath wird der richtigen erstmal
versuchen könnte
da traut sich nicht
nicht ganz aber es haben sich wenig
leute so clever angestellt wie du dieses
gibt es aber nichts gewusst
ihr seid so absicht
macht die kamera aus erwartet stellte
aktuell 92 abend fertig
[Musik]
hat mir spaß gemacht jetzt dreht ja
damit wir müssen unsere rechnung
schicken
für meinen kanal kann ich meinem trainer
gesagt siehst du nicht freut mich für
mich war halt ist eben selber
spd-sprecher ja also passiert während du
den ganzen tag die modelliert hast war
ich mir die jungs unterwegs und wir
haben die neuesten trends gesucht was
ist heimat was ist was ist gut was ist
nicht cool so hört und weiß was dieses
jahr der trend ist free from das heißt
vegan frei von zucker frei von gluten
frei von geschmack frei von allem und
geschmack und das war auch letzte
treffen falls ja auch nichts neues
nichts neues ist eigentlich ja du dir
selbst auch ein bisschen aber auch nicht
sagen ich muss ehrlich sagen wir haben
nicht viele trends gefunden erzählt wir
müssen ja okay und dann natürlich war es
auch ein trend sein wird in der zukunft
sei jetzt schon medical suite auf
deutsch heißt medizinische süßigkeiten
dankeschön mein englisch was gut sagt
manager suite sind ein süßigkeiten die
die sind gesünder machen oder gesund
bleiben lassen
ok insel skye genau und zwar auch
möchten wir ja gesund altern und
glücklich sterben
und deswegen gibt es jetzt bald medical
suite du ich was und es tue dir gut man
darin haben die kannst du kannst du
nicht ins dreifachen verlangt männliches
wie es heißt das ist auch dreifache
gekostet
okay war um bei einer mandarine verliert
er kein geld hatte vielleicht gestellt
und konvertiert und dann habe ich
natürlich paar coole sachen gekommen das
heißt verpackungen die recycelbar sind
dann was aber noch gefunden was mein arm
ja doch
was machst du
okay was auf das ist ein loser okay das
schmerzt nicht in zeitschriften
nein ihr habt jetzt drauf jemand mal auf
das ist ein luxus das ist auf dem titel
drauf okay was auch das ist der wahnsinn
das ist die weltneuheit und zeigen wie
es geht geben wir den handhelds
jetzt machen wir das weg danach ein
roboter warum kannst du mal zeigt nicht
dein ernst hat er mir jetzt ernsthaft
und 80er jahre zeitschriften tattoo pass
auf jetzt kommt nämlich der wahnsinn
jetzt nehme ich das handy ok mit dem
handy geht rauf er hat mir grand hotel
was ist gesehen hat es gesehen aber hier
siehst du das so und jetzt kann ich mit
dem roboter kann ich jedem furchtbar ich
kann kämpfen douglas den roboter kämpfen
ich kann der roboter roth machen
blaumachen grün malen schwarz malen und
ich kann den kämpfen weil jetzt sucht
der roboter rum und was findet stets
daran gut war aber ist wenn ich zwei
nebeneinander mache kann ich die roboter
dirk entlasten will das nicht heißt
chatter die zähne kaputt ja wieder hass
erzeugt sondern und tue was die haus
kaputt macht ja und dann noch hottie
kämpfen also ein dreifach sinnloses
produkt was eigentlich schade aber
richtig finster ist die kinder selbst
vielmehr am handy
wir wissen geschmäcker sind verschieden
das ist eine menge okay ich finde toll
marius kann es bestätigen marius
bestätigen marias das kind ist schon
sehr gefreut ja sie ist es gefeiert
ich fand es auch cool wie von selbst was
mir was man neuen trends haus gefunden
haben du warst die letzten
vier stunden mac und kaschmir intertour
verpasst und lutscher mitgebracht ja wie
soll ich jetzt ein video drehen ja toll
ein paar tolle geschichten erzählen
weißt du was die jungs kommt mir der mir
selber in die hand
wir gehen
[Musik]